angesichts des heißen wetters draußen
testen wir heute mal ein paar eis
rezepte aus dem internet und zwar
anzusehen und vor allem die einfachen
rezepte ohne eismaschine und wir waren
einfach mal gucken schmeckt das
überhaupt funktioniert das und sind
schon ganz gespannt
[Musik]
alles hätte ich und wir sind jetzt mal
wenn ich den kollegen geschmeckt dass
ich ein bisschen zusammen kompass ich
habe wirklich nicht gedacht dass das so
funktioniert also ich möchte wirklich
gut fast wie aus der eisdiele
das ist erdbeere
das schmeckt schon mal ziemlich gut
[Musik]
bisher war schon sehr süß was ist es
zwar sehr sage nicht mehr als ziemlich
süß als mir persönlich ist ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen zu süß aber das
steht so richtig schön cremiger
konsistenz also das hat er echt super
hingehauen
[Musik]
schmeckt richtig gut sehr natürlich
nicht so wie das künstliche wassereis
schön nach himbeere hinter geschmack es
ja ausgeprägt
[Musik]